c'était d'acheter des terres sur le continent,
pour que les Irlandais puissent y aller car leur île disparaissait sous les eaux.
Ce à quoi je n'avais pas à penser,
que ce soit comme dirigeant ou comme constitutionnaliste,
c'était les conséquences pour la souveraineté du territoire
à cause de l'impact du changement climatique.
Mais c'est ce à quoi le Président Tong, de la République de Kiribati,
doit penser tous les matins en se levant.
Il a acheté des terres aux îles Fidji comme police d'assurance,
pour ce qu'il appelle « une migration avec dignité »,
parce qu'il sait que son peuple devra peut-être quitter ses îles.
Lorsque j'ai écouté le Président Tong décrire cette situation,
j'ai vraiment senti qu'il y avait un problème
auquel aucun dirigeant ne devrait être confronté.
Et lorsque je l'ai entendu parler des douleurs que représentait ce problème,
j'ai pensé à Eleanor Roosevelt.
J'ai pensé à elle et à ceux qui travaillaient avec elle
à la Commission des Droits de l'Homme, qu'elle a présidée en 1948,
à qui nous devons
la Déclaration Universelle des Droits de l'Homme.
Pour eux, il aurait été inimaginable
qu'un pays entier soit rayé de la carte
à cause d'un changement climatique induit par l'homme.
Je suis venue au changement climatique ni comme scientifique
ni comme juriste environnemental,
et je n'étais pas vraiment touchée par les images d'ours polaires
ou de glaciers en train de fondre.
C'était à cause de son impact sur les gens
et son impact sur leurs droits,
leurs droits à la nourriture, l'eau saine, à la santé, à l'éducation et au logement.
Et je dis cela humblement,
parce que je suis venue tardivement à la question du changement climatique.
Quand j'étais Haut-Commissaire de l'ONU
aux Droits de l'Homme
de 1997 à 2002,
le changement climatique n'était pas ma priorité.
Je ne me rappelle pas avoir prononcé un seul discours sur ce sujet.
Je savais qu'il y avait une autre section de l'ONU --
-- la Convention sur le Changement Climatique --
qui s'occupait de ce problème.
Ce ne fut que plus tard,
quand j'ai commencé à travailler dans des pays africains,
sur la question du développement et des Droits de l'Homme.
Et j'entendais partout, continuellement, cette phrase :
« Oh, nous allons tellement plus mal maintenant, tellement plus mal. »
J'ai donc cherché ce qu'il y avait derrière cela ;
c'était une question de changement climatique --
de chocs climatiques, de changements dans la météo.
J'ai rencontré Constance Okollet,
qui avait formé un groupe de femmes en Est-Ouganda,
et elle m'a appris que quand elle était jeune,
elle avait une vie des plus normales dans son village, on ne manquait de rien :
on savait que les saisons passeraient comme elles le devaient,
on savait quand semer, et on savait quand moissonner,
et on avait assez de nourriture.
Mais, ces dernières années,
au moment de notre conversation,
ils n'avaient rien d'autre que de longues périodes de sécheresse,
et ensuite des inondations-éclair,
et ensuite la sécheresse.
L'école avait été détruite,
des cultures avaient été détruites,
leur moisson avait été détruite.
Elle anime ce groupe de femmes,
pour essayer de garder sa communauté à flot.
Et c'est une réalité qui m'a vraiment frappée,
parce que, bien sûr, Constance Okollet n'était pas responsable
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre à l'origine du problème.
De fait, j'ai été vraiment touchée par la situation au Malawi,
en janvier de cette année.
Il y a eu une inondation sans précédent dans le pays,
qui a recouvert environ un tiers du pays.
Plus de 300 personnes en sont mortes
et des centaines de milliers ont perdu leurs moyens de subsistance.
Et le Malawien moyen
émet environ 80 kg de CO2 par an.
L'Américain moyen en émet environ 17,5 tonnes.
Ceux qui souffrent de manière disproportionnée
n'ont pas de voiture, ni d'électricité, consomment très peu,
et cependant ils sentent de plus en plus
les impacts du changement climatique,
les changements qui les empêchent de savoir comment cultiver efficacement
et de savoir comment appréhender leur futur.
Et je pense que ç'a été vraiment l'ampleur de cette injustice
qui m'a frappée avec tant de force.
Et je sais qu'on ne peut pas régler cette injustice
parce que nous ne sommes pas sur le chemin d'un monde plus sûr.
Des pays du monde entier ont soutenu à la Conférence de Copenhague,
et ils ont répété cela à chaque conférence sur le climat,
que nous devions rester sous la barre des 2°C de réchauffement
au-dessus des standards pré-industriels.
Mais nous sommes sur le chemin des 4°C.
Nous devons donc faire face à une menace très importante
envers le futur de notre planète.
Et cela m'a fait réaliser que le changement climatique
était la menace la plus importante envers les Droits de l'Homme
au XXIème siècle.
Et cela m'a conduite ensuite à la justice climatique.
La justice climatique obéit à l'argument moral --
-- aux deux côtés de l'argument moral --
afin de traiter du changement climatique.
En premier lieu,
d'être du côté de ceux qui souffrent et qui sont affectés le plus.
Et deuxièmement,
de s'assurer qu'ils ne seront pas encore laissés pour compte,
quand nous commencerons à agir
et à nous occuper du changement climatique,
comme nous le faisons maintenant.
Dans notre monde très inégalitaire, aujourd'hui,
le nombre de laissés pour compte est effarant.
Dans notre monde de 7,2 milliards d'habitants,
près de 3 milliards sont laissés pour compte.
1,3 milliards n'ont pas accès à l'électricité,
et ils éclairent leurs maisons avec du kérosène ou des bougies,
les deux étant très dangereux.
Et ils dédient en réalité une grande part de leurs maigres salaires
à ce type d'éclairage.
2,6 milliards de personnes cuisent à feu ouvert
sur du charbon, du bois ou des excréments d'animaux.
Et cela cause environ 4 millions de morts par an
par asphyxie,
et, bien sûr, la plupart de ces morts sont des femmes.
Nous avons donc un monde plein d'inégalités,
et nous devons nous défaire de nos habitudes délétères.
Et nous ne devrions pas sous-estimer
l'ampleur et la nature fondamentale
du changement dont nous allons avoir besoin.
Car nous devons aller vers zéro émission à l'horizon 2050,
si nous voulons rester sous la barre des 2°C.
Et cela veut dire que nous devrons laisser deux tiers des ressources fossiles connues
sous la terre.
C'est un changement radical,
et ça veut dire qu'évidemment,
les pays industriels doivent réduire grandement leurs émissions,
doivent gaspiller beaucoup moins,
et doivent se tourner au plus vite vers les énergies renouvelables.
Pour les pays en développement et les économies émergentes,
le problème et le défi seront de se développer sans émission,
parce qu'ils doivent se développer ; leurs populations sont pauvres.
Ils doivent donc croître sans émission, et c'est un problème d'une autre sorte.
En effet, aucun pays ne s'est développé sans émission.
Tous les pays se sont développés avec de l'énergie fossile
pour peut-être, ensuite, passer aux énergies propres.
En somme, c'est un véritable défi,
et il requiert le soutien complet de la communauté internationale,
avec les finances, technologies, systèmes et soutiens nécessaires,
parce qu'aucun pays ne peut se garder des dangers du changement climatique.
C'est un problème qui requiert de la solidarité humaine totale.
La solidarité humaine, si vous voulez, fondée sur l'intérêt personnel --
parce que nous sommes tous concernés
et nous devons travailler ensemble,
pour garantir d'atteindre zéro émission en 2050.
La bonne nouvelle, c'est que le changement arrive,
et il arrive très vite.
Ici en Californie,
il y a un projet très ambitieux de réduction des émissions.
A Hawaï, on vote des lois
visant à atteindre 100% d'énergie renouvelable en 2045.
Et les gouvernements sont très ambitieux dans le monde entier.
Au Costa-Rica, ils se sont engagés à avoir un impact carbone neutre en 2021.
En Éthiopie, cet impact neutre est pour 2027.
Apple a promis que ses usines en Chine utiliseraient des énergies renouvelables.
Et il y a un engouement actuellement
pour tirer de l'énergie des marées et des vagues
afin de laisser le charbon dans le sol.
Et ce changement est à la fois bienvenu et a un rythme heureusement très rapide.
Mais ce n'est pas assez,
et la volonté politique n'est pas encore assez forte.
Laissez-moi revenir au Président Tong
et à son peuple des Kiribati.
Ils pourraient en fait vivre sur leur île et ont une solution,
mais cela requerrait beaucoup de volonté politique.
Le Président Tong m'a exposé son idée ambitieuse
de soit rehausser soit faire flotter les petites îles où vit son peuple.
C'est bien sûr au-delà des ressources des Kiribati elles-mêmes.
Cela requerrait beaucoup de solidarité et de soutien de la part des autres pays,
et cela requerrait le même type d'innovation
que celui employé pour la construction d'une station spatiale dans le ciel.
Mais ne serait-il pas incroyable de réaliser cette merveille d'ingénierie
et de permettre à un peuple de rester sur son territoire souverain,
et de faire partie de la communauté des nations ?
C'est le type d'idée auquel on devrait réfléchir.
Oui, le défis associés aux transformations dont nous avons besoin sont énormes.
mais ils peuvent être relevés.
Nous sommes en réalité, en tant que peuple,
parfaitement capables de nous unir pour résoudre des problèmes.
J'en ai vraiment pris conscience lorsque j'ai pris part cette année
à la commémoration du 70ème anniversaire
de la fin de la Seconde Guerre Mondiale, en 1945.
1945 fut une année extraordinaire.
Une année où le monde fut confronté
ce qui a dû paraître comme des questions quasi-insolubles :
la dévastation des guerres mondiales, -- surtout la deuxième --
la paix fragile qui en était sortie,
la nécessité d'une reconstruction économique complète.
Mais les dirigeants de cette époque n'ont pas reculé devant cet obstacle.
Ils avaient la capacité, ils se sentaient tenus
à cet impératif selon lequel le monde ne devrait plus jamais tomber si bas.
et ils ont dû construire les bases de la paix et de la sécurité
Et qu'avons-nous eu ? Quels furent les résultats ?
La Charte des Nations-Unies,
les institutions de Bretton Woods, comme on les appelle, la Banque Mondiale,
et le Fonds Monétaire International.
Un Plan Marshall pour l'Europe, une Europe dévastée,
afin de la reconstruire.
Et, de fait, quelques années plus tard,
la Déclaration Universelle des Droits de l'Homme.
2015 est une année aussi importante que 1945,
avec des défis et des possibilités de même nature.
Il y aura deux sommets cette année :
le premier, en septembre, à New York,
est le sommet pour les objectifs du développement durable.
Et ensuite le sommet de Paris, en décembre, pour un accord sur le climat.
Les objectifs du développement durable sont voués à aider des pays
à vivre de manière durable, en accord avec Mère Nature,
pas à exploiter Mère Nature, et à détruire des écosystèmes,
mais plutôt pour vivre en harmonie avec Mère Nature,
pour vivre selon un modèle de développement durable.
Et les objectifs du développement durable
vont rentrer en vigueur pour tous les pays très bientôt, le 1er janvier 2016.
L'accord sur le climat
-- un accord contraignant -- est requis
à cause de la preuve scientifique
selon laquelle nous nous dirigeons vers un monde des 4°C
et selon laquelle nous devons changer pour rester sous les 2°C.
Nous avons donc besoin de mesures qui seront contrôlées et revues,
afin de pouvoir accroître nos ambitions de réduction des émissions,
et de savoir comment passer rapidement aux énergies renouvelables
pour construire un monde meilleur.
La réalité est que ce problème est bien trop important
pour être laissé aux politiciens et aux Nations-Unies (Rires).
Nous sommes tous concernés par cette question,
une question pour laquelle nous avons besoin de plus en plus d'élan.
En effet, le visage des environnementalistes a changé,
à cause des questions de justice.
C'est maintenant une question pour les organisations religieuses
dirigées de manière éclairée par le Pape François,
et, de fait, par l’Église d'Angleterre,
qui se détache des énergies fossiles.
C'est un problème pour les entrepreneurs,
et la bonne nouvelle, c'est
que cette communauté change rapidement
-- sauf pour l'industrie fossile --
(Rires)
Même eux commencent à changer légèrement leur discours
mais très peu.
Mais le monde des affaires ne se dirige pas seulement
vers les énergies renouvelables,
il exhorte aussi les politiciens à plus de lisibilité
pour qu'il puisse avancer encore plus vite.
C'est un problème pour les syndicats,
pour le mouvement des droits des femmes,
c'est un problème pour la jeunesse.
J'ai été frappée quand j'ai appris que Jibreel Khazan,
un des Quatre de Greensboro,
qui avait pris part aux sit-ins de Woolworth,
dise assez récemment
que le changement climatique était la nouvelle Bastille de la jeunesse.
La Bastille des jeunes gens du XXIème siècle,
en quelque sorte le vrai problème des Droits de l'Homme du XXIème siècle,
car il a dit que c'était le plus grand défi
à l'humanité et à la justice dans notre monde.
Je me souviens bien de la Marche pour le Climat de septembre dernier,
et elle incarnait un élan énorme
pas seulement à New York, mais dans le monde entier.
Et nous devons construire là-dessus.
Je manifestais avec quelques-unes des familles des Sages Universels,
et j'ai vu une pancarte, un peu plus loin devant moi,
mais nous étions si serrés,
parce qu'après tout, nous étions 400 000 dans les rues de New York.
Et je ne pouvais pas aller jusqu'à cette pancarte.
J'aurais voulu pouvoir me tenir sous cette pancarte
parce qu'elle disait : « Mamies en Colère ! »
(Rires)
C'est ce que j'ai ressenti.
Et j'ai cinq petits-enfants maintenant.
En tant que grand-mère irlandaise, je suis très heureuse d'en avoir cinq,
et je pense à leur monde,
et comment ça sera quand ils partageront ce monde
avec 9 milliards d'autres personnes en 2050.
Nous savons qu'inévitablement, ce sera un monde contraint par le climat,
à cause des émissions que nous avons produites jusqu'ici,
mais ce pourrait être un monde beaucoup plus égalitaire et juste,
et bien meilleur pour la santé, pour l'emploi,
pour la sécurité énergétique,
que le monde présent,
à condition de changer suffisamment
et rapidement nos énergies en faveur du renouvelable
et de ne laisser personne en chemin.
De ne laisser personne en chemin.
Et comme nous avons regardé en arrière cette année
-- de 2015 à 1945, 70 ans en arrière --
j'aimerais pouvoir me dire, que les gens le feront,
que ce monde regardera 35 ans en arrière en 2050,
et que les gens diront :
« N'ont-ils pas bien agi en 2015 ?
Nous sommes heureux qu'ils aient pris les décisions qui ont fait la différence,
et qui ont mis le monde sur le droit chemin,
et nous jouissons maintenant de ce droit chemin » ,
qu'ils sentiront que nous avons su prendre nos responsabilités,
que nous avons fait ce qui avait été fait en 1945, dans des termes comparables,
que nous n'avons pas manqué cette opportunité,
ni été indignes de nos responsabilités.
C'est tout l'enjeu de cette année.
Et en quelque sorte, pour moi,
c'est contenu dans ces mots d'une personne que j'admirais beaucoup.
Elle a été un mentor, une amie,
elle est morte bien trop jeune,
c'était une personnalité extraordinaire,
un grande championne de l'environnement :
Wangari Maathai.
Wangari a dit un jour :
« Dans le cours de l'histoire,
il vient un moment où l'humanité est amenée
à passer à un autre niveau de conscience,
afin d'élever ses qualités morales. »
Et c'est ce que nous devons faire.
Nous devons arriver à un nouveau niveau de conscience,
élever nos qualités morales.
Et nous devons le faire cette année, au cours de ces deux grands sommets.
Et cela n'arrivera pas à moins d'avoir l'élan
l'élan de ceux qui diront de par le monde :
« Nous voulons de l'action maintenant,
nous voulons changer de cap,
nous voulons un monde meilleur,
meilleur pour nos générations futures,
meilleur pour nos enfants et nos petits-enfants,
et nous sommes tous concernés. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)